[Music]
now I've always said that chefs eat the
best food and the worst they work the
best ingredients and cook them perfectly
but their eating habits can be somewhat
a little awful now I know this firsthand
from my time in the kitchen and I gotta
have a shape and I felt a little
sluggish I knew I needed to take much
better care of myself a healthy
lifestyle involves eating well plenty of
exercise and right now I can't imagine
life without it I hope my new book
ultimate fit food will be the cookbook
for eating well and achieve an optimal
health and fitness
[Music]
[Music]
I want to be very clear I promise you
this is not a diet book there are no
fatty ideas about eating cabbage soup or
living off grapefruits and is not dull
now as a chef I'd only get bored eating
the same things over and over I never
ever ever want to feel somewhat the
crime ultimate fit food includes all my
go-to recipes I want to eat well at home
I hope these recipes inspire you to get
cooking and more importantly improve
your own health good luck
[Music]